Hugh Jackson's feeling it the Browns are
feeling it they are one one and one
right now through three weeks of the
Nationals he tried to deny us the talent
the NFL Network analyst and rider for
nfl.com along with fellow NFL Network
erm at Monte Smith he is the color
analyst for Los Angeles chargers radio
broadcasts meaning that it's a home game
for him this weekend as Chargers take on
the Rams whose color analyst Malik
Maurice jones-drew also the NFL Network
be joining us in the next hour good to
see you Daniel
good to see by tomorrow I I wanted a
start that sound buy - I guess station
as somebody who was evaluating this
talent over the last several months I
mean what do you think of that comment
right there well okay to me
he started I think 48 games in his
collegiate career so the development I
don't know what was really left I mean I
think he kind of arrived as a ready-made
player so the fact that he wasn't
playing early I don't know I feel like
it's almost like you're driving around
an amusement park like on a loop and go
and that's a great amusement park like
just get off the freeway and go go to
the amusement park it's right there you
keep circling around I know that's you
point out Brooklyn he's the one who is
denying the talent from starting but
look the bottom line is he got in
because the Jets helped release the it
that's what they do
yeah um so and we'll get to that in a
second in turn is that a hashtag yeah
release the hashtag admonish gets us
started your assessment of what you saw
from Baker Mayfield last night it was it
was know how you come away with any
other takeaway that was outstanding I
mean to me the biggest thing no fear no
hesitation trusted his eyes and got the
ball out what's working in the middle of
the field
you saw anticipation you saw velocity
you saw accuracy and the numbers could
have been even better I mean when you
look at some of the draw passes namely
the one to Callaway deep down the field
and more than anything else rich I it
sounds hokey but you could just you
could feel it you could feel the energy
in the stadium you could feel the energy
with his teammates it just he kind of he
kind of brought everybody up and that
was a lot of the things that were said
about him at Oklahoma you saw a lot of
those things come out last night so how
sustainable for to that that are gonna
sustain I mean when you can throw the
ball that accurately when you show that
type of poise and
and and that kind of no flinch mentality
I think that's something that's gonna
that's gonna maintain you're gonna see
that throughout the year now he's gonna
have slip-ups like any rookie would he's
gonna see coverages that he doesn't
recognize he's gonna make some mistakes
he's good
you saw sac force fumble last night
you're gonna see some of that was it
dropped interception zone you're gonna
see you're gonna see some some bumps in
the road but to me you've you've got
your guy at least it's it's one game but
right now small sample size I'd man I'd
be feeling great if you're Cleveland
okay and so what about darn 'old what do
you say fine okay I crack up at this I
mean you mentioned it three games in
what 10 11 days short week go on the
road you play against Greg Williams a
defense that's loaded with talent I'm I
said before the year I think Myles gear
it'll be the Defensive Player of the
Year I'm not backing off that from what
we've seen we could he's a freaking I
thought early on in that game he hit
darn old and Donnell get up a little bit
gimpy and I thought from that moment on
the Jets kind of made a decision like
we're gonna run the football and we're
gonna get it out quick we're not gonna
subject our young quarterback to a
beating back there and so everybody's
killing him
oh he's not throwing the ball down the
field and like he's not gonna have time
to throw the ball down the field they
did what they had to do so evaluate I
guess the idea of Mayfield versus darn
'old that we're gonna be seeing
throughout the entire day in jumps of
taking just uh I guess put a button on
that subject and it's in itself what we
saw last night from two rookie
quarterbacks under the lights how
sustainable are they do the both teams
have their guys beyond 2018 absolutely I
mean I've said when we were going
through this draft process I thought
this was an outstanding classic we
talked about a year ahead of time and
then as every year we start picking
these guys apart but I try to stay true
to and say look I think these guys are
franchise quarterbacks whenever we see
Josh Rose and you're gonna see it from
him as well now Josh Allen's a little
bit more of a longer term play but Sam
Donald what we saw week one on the road
that was impressive what we saw
week one for Baker Mayfield was
impressive and last week I mean Donnell
I think threw for 330 plus against the
Dolphins defense that's not bad I mean
he is he is going to be fine both these
teams are in good shape now as I told
the story about how on that Monday night
Jets win over the Lions as Isaiah
Crowell
ran in from about 70 yards out mm-hmm as
he creased the goal line my phone goes
off and it's you saying you just wanted
a contact hug from a jet fan so how good
are the Jets I mean what are they what
are they missing yeah and and I guess
let me let me just phrase it through
just last night what why couldn't they
stop Baker Mayfield I mean he were they
unprepared for him no I mean look they
got hot they got into a rhythm I think
that you're again on I on that short
week it looked like they just kind of
ran out of gas a little bit Baker
brought all that energy to Cleveland and
I thought that Jets look like once you
got into that second half there was not
there was just not a lot left there for
them and that being said they gave up
what 21 points or whether 21 17 was the
final score so you keep a team under you
know at 21 points you feel good about
your chances of winning the ball game
it's just a little bit short I think the
Jets team is is again is about more next
year I think the Cleveland roster right
now I would I would make a case
offensively there's more pieces there in
place with Cleveland and there are for
the Jets that's what they've got to do
in the future build up around the
quarterback Daniel Jeremiah here on the
Rich Eisen show are you going to
personally eyeball the best team in
football this weekend they are they are
a complete team when you when you watch
the Rams I mean I'm just disappointed if
Joey Bosa was healthy I think we could
be talking about really two of the two
of the two three or four best teams in
the NFL and I think the Chargers have a
chance to still get there that's just a
big piece you're missing up front so
tell me about beau so what's going on
with his foot best I don't know I don't
feel like it's been talked about much on
the on the national level we haven't
heard much about that this is one of the
best defensive players in all the
football all the the focus has been on
Khalil Mack in that trade well the
Chargers have been without one of the
best defensive players now last week
against Buffalo they were able to do
some things and find a pass rush and I'm
telling you when you when you watch this
game if people haven't watched the
Chargers yet watch number 33 from start
to finish while we're talking about
rookies Derwin James is a big-time dude
and if they're gonna beat the Rams this
week he's gonna be a big part of it so
how do you think the Rams who are
geniuses with the coach and the playbook
gonna scheme this weekend to try and go
to 3 and L against these Chargers what
do you think well it's it's it's gonna
be fascinating to see what they do
because they change it up they can morph
and whatever they want to do depending
on the week I would imagine we might see
a little bit more todd gurley a little
bit more of them trying to run the
football early on and try and establish
that against the Chargers front but you
know that's the thing about Shaun
McVeigh you watched the the opener
against Oakland went back and went
through that tape I think they ran four
or five fly sweeps in the first quarter
of that game my first a quarter and a
half and so then as a defense you're
scrambling we got to make adjustments
there and then he never runs it the
whole rest of the game it's like he just
gives you a little bit then it kind of
takes it away so he can he can change
this offense from week to week really
from quarter to quarter makes him so
difficult and then look let's shut out
the Cardinals last defense pretty darn
good yeah are they Cardinals you only
got across the 50 and in garbage time
with a minute a minute and change to go
do you think it's Josh Rosen time for
the Cardinals I don't know why again
it's the Mayfield thing what do we what
are we waiting for here I mean that the
only thing different I guess is the exam
it's a chunk of change therefore for a
short-term deal but come on but
especially after that performance as
futile as that was what I mean and and
rosin is another one he's played a lot
of football he's polished he's ready to
go
there's no that the development is not
really needed with him get him out there
but you've been in you've been in front
offices and in tape rooms you've been in
draft rooms I mean what goes through the
minds of an evaluator and a coaching
staff when you have an undeniable talent
at quarterback and you do not throw him
in the game and I'm not saying that that
is the reason that they should do it
every single time because look at my
homes obviously 15 games of watching
last year's regular season has one would
think helped him no question that seems
that seemed they had a better option
they had a good option in place there I
wouldn't say a better option a good
option in Alex Smith the team was
winning a lot of football games that
team I believe I haven't gone back and
checked but I'm pretty sure that Kansas
City team with Alex Smith was was
crossing the 50-yard line rather
frequently yes so a little bit different
situation there so who is the most
impressive quarterback you've seen this
week I mean I mean mahomes I saw him
Homes up close and in person with the
Chargers game week one and he's
outstanding but I also think that's a
combination now am i taking anything
away from Holmes he's been great but
Andy Reid is a play caller Tyriq Hill
and the pressure he puts on a defense
you've got Kelsey you've got Sammy why
they've got mismatches all over the
place and an Andy Reid finds a way to
match you up you go watch him against
the Steelers rich there's a play where
TJ watt is trying to cover Sammy Watkins
forty yards down the field that's not a
winning proposition for any defense but
Andy Reid every week finds a way to
generate these matchups and mahomes
executing that game plan beautifully the
brought about Fitzpatrick why is that
working in a way that Jamie Winston
could not get it to work over the last
few years Daniel there is I'm not
talking about Baker may feel playing
with no fear I mean Fitzpatrick
obviously you can tell by his attire
there's zero fear in him and it is ultra
aggressive he is he is literally he's
swinging for the fences down in and down
out and right now he's hitting
everything over the fence now eventually
he's gonna strike out and that's gonna
happen there's gonna be some some bumps
along the way here pretty soon it feels
like just the law of averages that's
coming but man they have gone big play
hunting everybody forgot about DeSean
DeSean and what he can do and Mike Evans
what he did to Marshawn Lattimore one of
the best young corners in the NFL week
one was pretty impressive so Daniel
Jeremiah I'd like you to draw upon all
of your experience and scouting and
evaluating and seeing as much film as
you do Jon Gruden is trying to put his
finger in Oakland on why there is no
pass road and how he can generate one
can you can you offer your two cents on
that subject it's very difficult it's
very difficult but circling back to
Baker may feel we've been you know quick
to praise him let's see how he does when
he gets up to Oakland he gets Khalil Mac
he's wait hold on a second what's that
he's not he's not there ya know the
interesting thing about Oakland is they
do have some good young defensive
linemen which that's a good thing but it
would be nice to see them complemented
by Khalil Mackie I think they could
actually have one of the best defensive
fronts we'll be talking about the
Raiders a bunch because Hurst is a
really good player as you know and an
ardent Keyes got a chance to be good and
then if you had Khalil Mack in that
front mm-hmm look a little different
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show with your feet planted firmly in
the NFL community and also the college
community and the scouting community all
over all who are talent evaluation about
at the collegiate level right now
through just a couple weeks into the
season now I was talking to an executive
with a team that's been out on a
scouting trip he's been all over seeing
a bunch of good players
so tell me who are the top guys just
give me some guys I want to stop
starting to watch some guys give me some
names and he just said well the Clemson
defensive line the Ohio State defensive
line and the Auburn defensive line I go
okay give me some numbers like which
guys he goes all of them okay all right
there you go good place to start
all of ya it's gonna be a loaded draft
four defensive linemen so hey maybe
maybe when when Oakland gets a chance
and they end up having two top ten picks
and they come away with two of these
guys they're on the cheap
maybe Gruden I'll have the last laugh
cuz that's where it's all eyes Nick
BOCES the one he's freaked he just got
hurt I mean he's gonna I don't know how
long he's gonna be out but I've seen
enough I mean I watched him over the
summer and he's he's one of those guys
where it doesn't matter the draft class
yeah he's up there so he'll you I mean
especially can install him potentially
is that pencil alignment is the number
one overall pick in Nashville next year
well we'll see what quarterbacks always
move the NATO if you need a quarterback
which ones do you think could move the
needle well Herbert's really interesting
from Oregon he's one to keep an eye on
he's just huge and I saw him before the
season started this year he's about 30
pounds heavier than he was the year
before I mean he looks physically like a
Josh Allen type guy so he's interesting
I love will Grier when I studied him at
West Virginia is a good player you've
got to sit him at Auburn who's a good
player true locks having a great year
they've got a big game this week a
chance for him to make a statement if he
goes up against that Georgia defense and
carves them up we'll be talking a lot
about him and how good is to him I mean
we had we had Trent Dilfer on on Monday
and you know he's known him since he was
I school and he he's been pounding the
table for 204 quite some time he says
he's the most special player he's ever
seen them in terms of throwing the
footballs well most gifted and as he
said he might he might not lose a game
in college I mean because of where he is
yeah how good is he you know I I'm
trying to be careful on you know
hyperbole with a guy he's just a
sophomore okay he still got to grow and
learn and develop all that kind of stuff
right I honestly think he's a he's not
he's not only a left-handed Russell
Wilson he's a better version of Russell
Wilson that's just left-handed I mean
that's that's what he can be I mean he's
outstanding just the instincts the
natural feel the pocket movement he
throws a beautiful ball I mean it just
got so much spin it
so pretty and the kid have you saw it he
takes the sack in the championship game
last year and you're like oh that's
there it is first crack got it that
they're done what a dummy and he just
threw the game-winning touchdown he just
responded just like that I don't want to
throw I mean
Jalen Hertz is gonna maybe play more
snaps than Tula when it's said and done
the way that they're here's my question
this would be a fun game for you to do
on the show everything every Monday
Brockman free of charge okay so when
Alabama beats these teams like they did
old miss 62 to 7 I believe it's what the
score was lastly it was indeed yes they
are blowing the doors off everybody but
you know that Saban always has to have
some teaching point and he's got to get
really upset who's that person so what
is he ups like every Monday what is he
upset about hey guys when we're
stretching and I want you four and a
half yards apart from each other and I
look at a tape and you're five and a
half yards apart that's unacceptable
like you've got to literally generate
something I don't know what you could
complain about it's always somebody
making a dumb penalty up 50 it's it's
it's the offensive coordinator not
running the ball to take the clock down
when they're I know it's usually that is
but he's got a.m. this weekend I mean
that's a gym bo is gonna win there he's
gonna win there soon I was down there
before the season started our chance to
visit with him and watch them practice
and I went into their room and saw their
recruiting board of what they've got
coming in they're right they're gonna
win quick and you know you're again
calling the Chargers and Rams Maurice
jones-drew coming in here top of them in
here's to our he calls the Rams game
yeah we could say it really is a battle
for Los Angeles because USC and UCLA law
so have you looked at UCLA schedule rich
it's not maybe one really maybe one feel
so it go through it Brockman and tell me
where things are in the middle well he's
pulling that up what's it what's wrong
with us see why are they not they're not
they're not good up front and I've been
saying this for a while now if you look
over the last five or so years Zac
banners like one of the only offensive
linemen they've had get draft and he was
drafted out on a fourth round he's been
on three different teams he's not really
a big-time player the days of the tie
Ron Smith the the Khalil brothers even
you know you go back to when they had
those championship teams they were put
in linemen in the first second third
round every single year they're not good
up front and you saw that against Texas
how does that happen four or five star
kids every year something's happening
between when they get on campus and when
they're leaving is the same thing I'm
hearing from Michigan is that you know
the offensive line isn't performing up
to usual Michigan standards I mean
that's one way there's no excuse at
those schools do not have gaps what I'm
wondering you know Braylon Edwards put
it a different way
hit the UCLA schedule real quick here
with Daniel Jeremiah at Colorado this
week that's a law that's a loss home
from Washington that's a loss at kau
Cal's pretty good there not bad right
home for Arizona that's the one I
thought you got a win going okay home
for Utah not beating Utah at Oregon not
beating Oregon at Arizona State not
beating her home for USC home for
Stanford it's a one or two win team Shh
for Chip Kelly's first year ouch bed
ask the poll question brought to you by
TrueCar before I introduced the G the
poll question of Daniel Jeremiah and the
listening and viewing audience car
shopping can be confusing with terms
like dealer price list price and invoice
true car shows you what other people
paid for the car you want you can
recognize a good price when you're ready
to buy newer used visit true car to
enjoy more confident car buying
experience Chris have at it looking at
to know teams which is the most Fugazi
bengals Broncos bucks
dolphins ooh that is a good question you
know the Broncos are they're an
interesting team I mean because
defensively I love what they have
defensively Case Keenum is is a little
bit of a roller coaster latency looks
like they might have found a better huh
yeah ultra productive just didn't have
the size that you know that kind of kept
him from being on the radar but man he's
been great he is a great kid I know if
your chance to visit with he awesome he
didn't just give his 32 anybody for any
reason to it's awesome like some helada
so you choose the Broncos and that yeah
I just don't know with them you know I
feel like the Dolphins I've said they'd
be a 10 and 16 I got a lot of laughs on
that one but I think defensively they're
pretty darn good and offensively up
front you know it's funny we we are so
quick to you know we'll put guys in the
Hall of Fame after a couple starts and
we'll kill guys Laremy Tunsil rich is
playing really good right now okay there
you go that whole bust thing you can put
that aside all right we'll do that
move the sticks on Twitter the move the
sticks podcast you
with Bucky Brooks it's awesome enjoy
calling games this weekend can I give
you one thing for mjd please
neutral field I'll take appstate over
UCLA any day of the week any day of the
week let's not get this done I might be
in the green room right now all the way
from LAX we just landed hey you almost
got Penn State we almost end the misery
almost loudly I do appreciate your text
when we come close on those it's very
nice and that's why you called me when
the Jets were up good to see you to see
but why it's Daniel Jeremiah the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience